foreign
[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Friday August 12th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
the Federal Trade Commission is
launching an effort to expand online
privacy protections the regulator is
getting the ball rolling on a process to
create new rules targeting online
surveillance and lacks data security
practices by tech companies at a press
conference on Thursday FTC chair Lena
Khan spoke about why the agency was
taking this step the FTC for many years
over two decades now has really been on
the front lines of using our existing
enforcement tools to combat privacy
violations and data security breaches
but we've seen now that the growing and
continuing digitization of our economy
means that some of these practices may
now be prevalent and that case-by-case
enforcement may fail to adequately deter
law breaking or remedy the resulting
Harms when the rules do come out they
could fundamentally change the way our
data is gathered and used by tech
companies but while this is just the
beginning of the process the rules are
already facing criticism
joining us to discuss why that is and
what that could mean for our life online
is wsj reporter John McKinnon hi John
thanks for being here nice to be with
you so let's start with you this is
early days for the rulemaking process
but can you kind of lay out what the
goal for these rules is going to be well
the big goal is to just first figure out
if there is a real problem here in the
online environment that the FTC needs to
address so they're going to be taking a
lot of input and comment from the public
and from businesses and from advocacy
groups to try to figure out the extent
of the problems there are two main
problems here that they're trying to get
at one is whether people's privacies
really being violated in some meaningful
Way by all of the data collection and
targeted advertising and surveillance
that goes on on the internet and the
second issue is the question of whether
people's data is being handled in a way
that makes it vulnerable to hacking and
you know all the problems like identity
theft that flow from that
you who aren't as familiar with the FTC
and and its processes how far could this
rulemaking go I mean I realize now
they're just kind of looking at the
extent of the problem but were they to
make rules how extensive could they be
well they could ultimately go pretty far
I mean they've gotten petitions from
advocacy groups calling on them to for
example just ban surveillance
advertising in other words
individualized targeted advertising on
the internet
these groups say you know this is an
invasion of privacy and it leads to all
kinds of abuses
and therefore we ought to just get rid
of it
yeah I guess that gets to my next point
I mean who would be most impacted if
there were any changes here definitely
social media companies use of algorithms
to Target content to their users is one
big area that could be affected
but the biggest of all is certainly
advertising I mean and you're already
hearing sort of an outcry from industry
groups that are concerned that the
advertising economy could be upended by
this because it's so dependent on
people's data yeah let's talk a little
bit more about that criticism because
the FTC just announced on Thursday that
it was going to be making these changes
and already there has been some
criticism and what are critics upset
about well certainly the business
Community is concerned that this is
going to have you know tremendous
impacts on their advertising economy and
then you also are hearing from people
like the Chamber of Commerce that this
is basically something that is the
purview of Congress more than the FTC
and that the FTC just doesn't have the
authority to do some of the things that
they're going to be considering
yeah I mean when it comes to Congress
you know that was something that one of
the Commissioners Rebecca Slaughter
raised at the press conference on
Thursday until there's a law on the
books the commission has a duty to use
all the tools we have under current law
to address unlawful Behavior I see our
efforts as complementary
not an alternative to Congressional
legislation
how are Skeptics reacting to that and
how could these rules be complementary
well there is a concern that that the
FTC is going to do something that is
effectively going to discourage Congress
from acting so I mean it's hard enough
for Congress to to really do anything
and once you have you know other
government agencies
trying to do things that are pretty much
the same thing that Congress is trying
to do Congress has a tendency some
people say to just stop trying to do the
things that it's doing Congress has been
considering privacy legislation for
you know years but in the last six
months or so it's really gotten some
momentum and a comprehensive privacy
Bill actually passed the house Commerce
Committee a few weeks ago which is an
extraordinary step I mean I don't think
that it ever really happened before
and now you have the FTC trying to do
essentially the same thing so there's
you know some concern I think that this
FTC action is going to tend to sap some
of the momentum in Congress for doing
legislation
and Advocates I think particularly in
the business Community are are worried
that the FTC would go a lot further and
do a lot of things that Congress would
really never muster the political will
to do okay but time and time again on
this show when we talk about a law that
Congress is debating putting into place
when it comes to Tech everybody tells me
that like it's kind of a wait and see
game and it's hard to get Congress to
agree on anything so how realistic is it
that this privacy Bill turns into a law
I can't really give you odds but it is
definitely true that you know Congress
has gotten further in the last six weeks
then it's really ever gotten before so
yeah it's hard to say that this would
happen this year but it's very possible
that it could happen in the next year or
so and so I think that's one reason why
the FTC Commissioners today were very
careful to say you know what we're
trying to do is only complementary to
what Congress is trying to do and we're
not trying to you know usurpers to plant
them
all right that's our reporter John
McKinnon thanks for joining us John you
bet thank you
and that's it for Tech news briefing
this week our producer is Julie Chang we
had production assistants from Ariana
osparu our supervising producer is Chris
zinsley our executive producer is
kateriokum and I'm your host Zoe Thomas
thanks for listening and have a great
weekend
[Music]
[Music]